please
get on the ground
why not in the head that's what an armed
suspect asked after he was injured in an
officer-involved shooting sir please
I got to hurt you please drop the gun
drop the gun
[Music]
San Diego County California on May 7th
just after 12 30 PM dispatch received a
call for a man with a gun at the church
of Christ 9-1-1 emergency
hi um we have someone with a gun on the
premises
um we are at 1418 Crye Jewel Vista
California
92084 uh Church of Christ okay where
exactly is he at the church I believe
he's from the other building and someone
came in and said that he was holding a
gun to his head so he has a gun on him
the caller tells 9-1-1 dispatch people
inside the church cannot leave safely
are you guys going to send something
yeah yeah ma'am I have I have lots of
deputies on the way there right now the
whole time that we've been talking I'm
just getting additional information to
provide the depth yeah that they were
asking me to have you guys exit the
building so you telling me that you
can't do that
we can't exit the building safely I'm
not sure where to see like if he's like
I'm not sure what's going on in the
other building and then the premises are
very open like there's no there's only
like one date and then only one side of
the gate is open and then people will
have to like run to their carts and I
don't know how excited that would be
body camera video from the San Diego
County Sheriff's Office shows deputies
arriving on the scene working to locate
the suspect that he has a gun and we're
here now to make sure that no one else
gets hurt or no one gets hurt so we need
information okay and we'll be the ones
that are stepping in now from this point
on okay so where which building is it
when officials get eyes on the suspect
they call for him to move closer
is that him right there yes yes what
okay yes please Hey sir that's him with
the stick or the cane
okay all right hey I need you to walk
towards me sheriff's deputies then speak
with the suspect's grandson and call for
the suspect to drop the weapon are you
his grandson
okay walk towards me walk towards my
partner please right over there hang out
with him okay Hey sir
hey drop the gun drop the gun for Me Put
the gun down put it on the ground put it
on the ground drop it drop it on the
ground
sir drop the gun on the ground for me
please
sir put the gun sir drop the gun please
hey hey I need you to listen drop the
gun for me please sir please sir please
please drop the gun
drop the gun sir the suspect's grandson
can be heard on the recording begging
him to drop the gun but he continues
moving toward First Responders carrying
the weapon in hand sir please the gun
down I don't want to hurt you please
drop the gun drop the gun
around drop the gun for me please sir
put it on the ground I think
sir put the gun on the ground sir please
sir please
please
I don't want to have to shoot you
please drop the gun please
[Music]
after the shooting officials rushed to
the suspect's aid and created a
tourniquet for where he was wounded
audio captures him asking police why he
was not shot in the head
the suspect was taken to a hospital
where he is now recovering with
non-life-threatening injuries officials
are not releasing his name publicly and
say he will not face any charges right
now the shooting is still under
investigation reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie